my name is on Scott would my name is
Hans cobalt I'm in France with my wife
for the European Championships roofing
we're Germany fans and we arrived in
Paris in this campus box on Thursday go
through my brush your fingers through
your hair and you're ready you throw on
a jersey some shorts and that's all you
need to do in a hotel you always have to
look trendy we've been camping now for
25 years as much nicer as food trainer
Vince Kazan we traveled seven hundred
and fifty kilometers from southern
Germany we come from Bavaria besides
there's a longer those saw blind members
that we stay with our camper vans going
wherever we like for one day two days
three and when we don't like it anymore
we move on we also meet really great
people and that's the beauty of it
should resume we're passionate
supporters so of course we hope that
Germany wins the opening game for us the
German supporters rewards my eyes I've
gone to one to Germany on it no way 31
you do Ross keeps on what could be
better every four years there's a
European Championship then every four
years there's a world cup and it's like
a dream when your heart and soul is in
sport obviously
the boxes are